- Somebody who
makes $80,000 a year
being a blogger about basketball
is like being the
12th man on a team.
You made it to the League,
but you're not LeBron.
You're one of the best
basketball players in the world,
but nobody knows who
you are kind of thing.
There's no shame,
as a matter of fact,
the practicality of
making $80,000 a year
being a blogger about
basketball, 'cause you love it,
versus making
$109,000 a year as a lawyer
is a great
arbitrage for a lot of people.
It's the unlocking happiness.
Is your life better making
$109,000 a year being a lawyer
versus making $80,000 a year
being a full-time
basketball content provider.
I don't know
people's situations.
You may have loans,
you may have this,
but if you can afford it,
I promise you,
you're gonna be way happier
doing the stuff
that you wanna be doing.
And those are choices everybody
has to make for themselves,
but when I say, "Not
everybody's gonna be LeBron,"
I mean, "Not everybody's
gonna be Mark Zuckerberg
"and Steve Jobs."
- [DRock] As an entrepreneur.
- That's right, got it?
- [DRock] But within
their hobbies and their job
and making their
career their hobby.
- That's right.
They can be the 17th, 19th,
there's a level of practicality
that's different for everyone
predicated on how
fancy they wanna be.
Where's your happiness?
And where is the things you
want that you need money for?
Where's that Mendoza Line?
There's a lot of
people, for example,
right now, who
are watching this,
who are doing well and
making $200,000 a year,
but if they made 140,
they'd be much happier.
Got it?
They start working,
the machine takes over,
that business eats them up.
A lot of people
think that happens to me
when they don't understand me.
They don't get it.
I already won.
I've won.
I'm getting to play
the game that I wanna play.
I don't need to make more.
It's not like
I need to make more.
I need to make
more because it means
that I'm succeeding in
the game that I'm playing.
- [DRock] And that's
where your patience comes in.
- Of course,
I'm ultimately patient.
I've already won.
DRock, this game's vigged.
I already won.
I figured myself out,
I know what makes me happy.
Nothing in the world makes
me happier than being able...
And, by the way,
this is for everybody.
Everybody is the
happiest when they get to do
what they want to be doing.
When you get to
do what you wanna do,
you've won.
That is the seductive
nature of entrepreneurship,
because you have control.
There's no boss.
But the company
can become your boss.
Overextending yourself
and paying for your lifestyle
can become your boss.
Not paying attention to
what makes you happy anymore
can become your boss.
And that's why I try to
stay grounded in that stuff.
When people don't know me,
and a video goes viral,
they're, like, "Oh, this
guy's just gonna be miserable,
"'cause he just
wants to make money."
You don't know me.
There's plenty of
people that are miserable
that are home all day.
Misery doesn't come in
the way you want to judge it.
Misery comes in the way that
it is for that actual person,
and for me,
the time I get to
spend with my family,
and then the fact that
I get to spend a lot of time
playing the game
that I wanna play,
is ultimate happiness.
I would suffocate and die
if I worked nine to six.
I wouldn't be happy.
Sorry that's not
politically correct.
It's selfish.
I wanna work that six to nine
that so many of you go
out to dinner with friends
or watch shows or play
volleyball or a part of that.
That's what I'm doing.
It's just three
more hours of work.
My meeting is your card club.
My meeting is your book club.
My meeting is
your pool table night.
My meeting is your dart team.
My meeting is your going
to the shore and surfing.
My meeting is your yoga.
You don't understand.
That's what makes me happy,
that's what makes me relaxed.
I get relaxed when I'm working.
I'm sorry I'm
not wired like you.